hi everyone this is Kostas polias with
my recording talk for itcs 2023 on the
paper online learning and bandits with
great hints this is Joint work with
Aditya bhaskara of the University of
Utah
of the University of California Merced
srinivas colapote of Google research and
cames for Duke University
so in this work we study a model for
hints for two traditional problems
online linear and convex optimization
and multi-ann bandits uh now let's start
by looking at the first problem uh
online linear optimization and what we
have is a bounded decision space capital
D that has three dimensions at each time
step T the algorithm will get to choose
a decision point x sub T in the decision
space
after the algorithm does does that
nature will reveal uh in an adversarial
fashion linear cost Vector C of t
the cost that the algorithm occurs is a
function of c and x c of T and X of t
in the linear case it's a DOT product
between CP and X of T but more generally
it can be a convex function
let's look at an example in this context
online shortest paths in this case the
decision space is the set of paths
between two designated endpoints s and t
in the graph
the dimension of the problem here is
given by the number of edges
and it's time step T the algorithm will
pick one path P of T and then nature
will reveal the edge lengths the cost
that we will incur is the length of the
path that we picked in this particular
round for the costs that nature gave us
observe that in this case the decision
space has exponential size but we can
efficiently optimize over it and you
should be thinking of these of these
types of settings for the results that I
will mention next
now what is the pen smart that we will
compare against what is the metric that
we will use uh defense Mark is the
standard best fixed action in hindsight
so overall the points X in the decision
space the one that minimizes the
accumulated cost over the time Horizon
capital T let's call this opt the metric
we care about is the regret of the
algorithm gets this opt so the
accumulated all cost of the algorithm
over all T rounds minus right right so
Central results tell us that under
exists an algorithm that achieves regret
that is order of square root t for this
model and this is the optimal that we
can do
however recently researchers have tried
to improve this result uh by looking at
the case of hints even to the algorithm
before the decision is made and they're
very proud
a hint h of T tells us something about
cost Vector C
right and the motivation behind this is
that we have an auxiliary machine
learning model that makes a prediction
about the cost effective right now in
this framework there are three
properties that we typically care about
the first one is termed consistency it
means that if the ins are correct if
they're very good then the regret should
be very low or vanish
on the opposite side we have robustness
which is that if the hints are really
bad then the regret should revert
to what we can achieve in the case of no
hits so in this case it should be volume
of square root T finally we have the
property of weakness which is coupled
with consistency it says that we want to
achieve consistency but without very
strong or explicit hints weaker hints
should suffice and again the goal is to
compare against the optimal action in
hindsight
now let's look at what what does it mean
to have a strong hit or a weak Heat a
strong hint
is a vector h of T that tries to
directly predict the cost Vector C of t
and then previous work tells us how the
regret goes down as this prediction gets
better and better and the expression
that you see here on the slide a weaker
hint would be some idea about the
direction of C sub T right so H these
are vector such that the dot product
with CD is a positive number
another idea for weekends is that b of
the hints can be completely wrong
previous work tells us that we can get
regret that is order of square root B
plus one times log t under some
restrictions such as the decision space
being close to the euclidean ball
now let's look at the hint model that we
study in this work
we think of it as the algorithm choosing
a direction rather than being given a
direction and we also consider the case
where B of the hints are completely
wrong so what do we mean by the
algorithm choosing the direction
typically what happens is that the
algorithm picks two decision points
rather than one
uh it passes these two points to the
auxiliary ml model which tells us which
one of the two is better so on which
direction
um the
um the algorithm should move and
typically we will play the point given
by the ml model
right so as a preview the results that
we will get uh as order square root B
plus one for any boundary decision space
in the linear optimization model this
result extends to the case of convex
cost functions and convex decision
spaces and later on for the monthly
unbonded setting when all the hints are
correct we will see that we can obtain
regret that is order of log t
all right now let's start with the
linear optimization setting and talk
about the algorithm the analysis and to
do so we will need some components from
previous work so let me go over them
first
um the first one is Follow the Leader
type algorithms Follow the Leader is an
algorithm that looks at the cost
accumulated by its action over all
previous time steps and playing the
option that minimizes that
so it's not hard to see that this would
be overfeeding to the Past
a stronger version of it is the one
called be the leader which looks at the
cost accumulated over all previous
rounds but including the current one so
this means that it's not something that
we can play it's in feasible
um strategy because we don't know the
cost of the current ground it's more of
a thought experiment but if we could
play that we would get an algorithm that
has zero regret
now a middle ground between the two can
be achieved using regularization
in the sense of summing up the cost
vectors observed in all previous rounds
and adding some noise to them if the
noise is of the sort of D over ETA where
D is a dimension and ETA is a parameter
we know that this will increase the
regret by an order of one over ETA so if
we apply this to be the leader we'll get
be the regularized leader we will get an
order of 1 over ETA regret
a second component that we will use is
the concept of differentially private
noise
so if the noise we add to its Dimension
is an independent laplacian 2D over ETA
and we do that on
yet Follow the regularized Leader if we
apply that or Follow the Leader and we
get a distribution G of T over possible
decision points
we do the same thing on be the leader to
get be the regularized liter which
induces a distribution h of T over
possible decision points uh differential
privacy implies that these two
distributions are close 0.1 so for every
decision the probability in one versus
the other is within a multiplicative e
raised to the end
now given this let me describe what our
algorithm is actually doing at its time
step T we will draw two samples from the
cost Vector accumulate up to point T
minus 1 plus the laplacian noise on each
one of the dimensions
we will get
the optimal decision point for the first
cost Vector the optimal addition point
for the second cross Vector we will pass
them on to the auxiliary ml model it
will tell us which one of the two is
best and we are going to play that
now let's think of coupling this
algorithm would be the regularized
leader be the regularized leader draws a
sample from the accumulated cost
including the current time point and has
the laplacian noise to it and then this
induces a distribution over decision
points
our algorithm draws two samples
from the accumulated cost Vector up to
the previous time point plus the
laplacian noise and this again induces
some distribution over decision points
we can argue that these two
distributions G and H actually do
satisfy the data differential privacy
which means they also satisfy the
defensive privacy property of the
distributions being pointwise within a e
raised to the data
and then this brings us to our key Lemma
which says that if we have these
properties and we choose parameter ETA
correctly which in our case means less
than 0.4 we will get that the expected
cost of our algorithm will be less than
or equal to the expected cost of build a
regularized leader which implies a
regret of
um order one over ETA which in our case
is a constant
now considering imperfect hints and the
case where B of the hints are wrong we
will assume here that we know B even
though I will note that this assumption
can go away with the standard doubling
tricks and the property that we can
observe after each round whether the
hint was correct or not let's assume for
now that we do know this number B
we need to modify the algorithm a little
bit we will do so by updating parameter
ETA to be one over five times square
root of B plus one
and we will introduce a new probability
parameter that is p which is equal to
five types ETA the algorithm will again
draw two cost vectors with laplacian
noise find the two optimal decision
points for each one of the fourth two
vectors
and then what they are going to do is
query the ml model but not always play
what the ml model says play that with
the probability p
and
play the first decision point I would
probability one minus P so probably one
minus p in some sense it follows the
algorithms follow the regularized here
this will induce a modification of the
key level that I mentioned before
and now it becomes that P times the cost
of following the hint plus one minus P
times the cost of doing Follow the
regularized Leader is less than or equal
to the cost of being the regularized
leader
and then the analysis will proof will
proceed with the case analysis where
um
we know that on the steps where the hint
is correct we don't incur any additional
regret so we can focus on the B steps
where the input is wrong
and we have two cases and the first one
is probably one minus P where we make
the same decision as Follow the
regularized Leader and we look at
um
the two sub cases with probability one
minus ETA the decision to follow the
regular isolator is the same as with the
regularized leader so no additional
redirect incurred so with the remaining
probability ETA we have a regret first
time step that is constant so we get a
total regret of order of B times ETA
which is with these with their choices
of our parameters uh square root of B
plus one
and the second case would probably in P
we actually use the wrong hint and very
great first step is constant for these
for these steps so get a total regret of
B times P order of B times P which again
comes out to square root of B plus one
for the parameters that we have chosen
so this wraps up the first setting and
we move on to the case of multi-arm
Bandits
in multi-arn bandage we have
uh n
um arms that we have to pick one in
every round the difference is from the
previous setting is that now let's first
of all let's switch to Awards rather
than costs for resetting now very words
here are not chosen adversarially they
come from unknown distributions one for
each arm these distributions are
independent and we can we will write mu
I for the mean of distribution I and
sigma I squared for its variance
the second difference is that once we
play an arm at a given time step
we only get to observe the reward for
that particular arm and not for the
other machine Again The Benchmark that
we compare against is the optimal action
the optimal fixed action uh the reward
of which in this case can be written as
T times mu star where T is the time
Horizon and new star is the optimal mean
now here classical results tell us that
the best we can achieve is order of
square root n times t
now the hint model is very similar to
the one we saw in the previous section
at time T the algorithm gets to pick two
arms A and B we ask the ml model which
one of the two is best we get a response
and we play that R here we will assume
that the hints will be correct in every
round and again we will try to match uh
the uh
we will compare Against The Benchmark of
multiple fixed action
the result that we will get is that the
regret will be of the order of n Square
Times log T so we get exponentially
better dependence on the time Horizon
now again before I Define the algorithm
I'll give you some components that we
will use in this case it will be the
ucbv algorithm which maintains over its
run for every arm the number of times
that it has been played s i of t uh the
mean of the samples we have observed m i
of T and the variance that we have
observed v i of t squared
given all these ucbv defines the score
on the arms which is pretty much the
mean plus an optimism parameter Which is
higher for higher variance and higher
four arms that have been played fewer
times
yeah
now to analyze the regret of ucbv we
need to define capital r of I which is
the expected regret uh we will get over
the run of the algorithm by playing arm
I and capital Delta of I which is the
difference between the mean of this arm
and the mean of the optimal are from Nu
star minus Nu I
now we know from previous work that the
regret we will get on arm I will be
given by this expression so 10 times
the variance over the difference from
the best arm plus one times log t
so we get lower regret if the arm has
smaller variance
and we get higher regressive the arm is
close to New Star because it will be
played more times
all right now let's see how our
algorithm works and how its analysis
proceeds and our algorithm will be
defined on meta arms so on pairs of arms
we get each pair of possible arms and we
call it a meta arm in this case and we
will run ucbv on The Meta arms
so if meta arm I comma J is the one that
has the highest score at time T we will
query the ml model give two words I and
J and we will ask
which one of the two is uh is better
um so
the reward for these meta arms follow
the distribution that is the maximum of
the two distributions between the two
arms and then we can Define the new IJ
to be the mean of this distribution
now to look at the analysis we will
define capital M star which is the maxim
which is pretty much the mean of the
best meta arm and we will have Capital
Delta i j which is similar to what we
had before for the single arms the
difference between a meta arm and the
optimal meta are
now the regret will be measured the
great capital I FJ will be measured
against
M Star so the optimal meta R which as
you can understand as you see here from
the picture is better than the best
fixed arm because the optimal meta arm
can have the best fixed arm and
something else
with this something else can be better
than the uh the arm that has the maximum
new star in some of the rounds so this
metal arm can get something higher than
the best fixed arm
now if we just plug in these values on
the result from cpv we get this
expression here at the bottom
and now this brings us to our key Lemma
which in this case says that
for meta arms that have
um mean rewards lower than the optimal
single arm
then their difference Capital Delta i j
from the optimal meta arm is greater
than or equal to their variance divided
by 4.
right so given this technical demo
if we plug it into the theorem for ucbv
you will see that the dependence on the
variance
and the capital Delta vanishes and we
get that the regret of a given meta RMS
at most order of log t
if we sum that over all the meta arms
are worse
than the optimal single arm
we get that the reward will be at most n
Square log d
uh obviously any other meta armor will
not enter any regret will be better than
the and on the optimal fixed action
so now I will mention one other setting
that we consider in this paper very
briefly and move on to conclusions and
open questions
uh the model is called the all probe
query model and the difference from what
we saw with the previous model for
multi-ann Bandits is that we will play K
arms more General than just two let's
say chaos
um
and we will get as a hint in the reward
of all the K arms that we played rather
than just the one that we will pick in
the end of course we will play the one
that is best but we will get feedback
for all the chaos that we that we picked
again comparing against the same
Benchmark as before the results that we
get is that if we can play three arms k
equals three then we can achieve
regardless order of N squared so it has
no dependence on the time Horizon
and
finally if the rewards are independent
across time like before but the arms are
correlated
with each other then if we can play Four
Arms we will get a regret that is of the
order of n raised to the N over three
times T raised to the one over three
all right so now to conclude what we saw
here is that this model of create ends
they are weak in the sense of the
definition that I mentioned before uh
but they are also powerful hints that
can leverage existing results in
interesting ways and improve them
now in terms of open questions that
follow from this work first one would be
to tighten the results we got on the
Bandit problems
uh maybe you realized I mentioned at
some point that meta arms can be better
than the best
single arm so regret can become negative
and we're not using this in the analysis
um and can we get another question is
can we get similar improvements for the
adversarial Bandit set as opposed to the
stochastic one that we use here
finally can results be extended to the
contextual Bandit setting and more
generally can this model of Queen hints
be applied to other Online problems so I
would encourage you to read the paper
and
look at these open questions
and thank you so much for listening I
hope you have a good time at the
conference